hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs will solve all the
major problems of the world so to help
you on your journey today I'm going to
talk about the seven fundamental truths
that will change your life and as always
guys as you listening if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it in comments below
that's what quotes around it so other
people can be inspired and the more you
write it down for yourself the more
likely it's going to stick in here as
well enjoy truth number one is you are
what you consistently do if you look at
your calendar you look at your doing on
a daily regular basis that is what's
going to determine your future path so
if you eat one chocolate bar but the
rest of your day is pretty healthy
you're going to be a healthy person but
if you're eating junk and more junk and
then pizza and the Burger King and more
burgers and more junk afterwards and
then you eat one piece of broccoli this
thing you're going to be healthy working
out once won't make a big difference for
you working out three times a week or
working out every day you'll see changes
in your life and so if you apply this to
your business if you have a goal if you
have a dream if you have something you
want to pursue you are what you
consistently do doing it one is on
enough doing it once a week is likely
not enough as well you have a plan you
want to accomplish a big goal you need
to find time every single day to focus
on it to take some kind of movement so
you building momentum so that that dream
happens you are where you consistently
do not what's in the exceptions number
two is your daily habits that you up for
success so in order to be what we
consistently are then you need to set up
your day so that every morning you
create the routines that sets you up for
that perfect day I'm a big believer that
the first habit that you do sets you up
for the rest of the day and so if you
are consistent with that habit then
you're consistent with everything else
that you want to do so an easy one is
making the bed so if you make the bed
then you're not just making the bed
you're the kind of person who sets a
goal and follows through and then you're
much more likely to the next step
the next step in the next step so a lot
of people have a daily routine in an
ideal world of I want to wake up on I
want to make the bed and I want to have
green tea and I want to meditate I want
to do some yoga after that and I want
mindfulness and gratefulness and I want
to work out and I'm going to start my
day
you know you have this huge long thing
which is possible to do but if your
first thing is really hard if your goal
for example is I want to wake up but I
want to go for a 30-minute run that run
is painful
once you're running you're good but
getting the shoes on and going out the
door is painful so it's much easier to
start with something simple because it's
likely if you miss that run you're going
to miss everything else that's for your
schedule but if you hit that run you're
gonna stay consistent so that morning
thing the very first thing that you do
become super important it's why I
created the hashtag BTA or you guys what
I wanted you to do is wake up every day
watch a video that inspires you where
you're learning something and then
writes hashtag BTA with the number of
consecutive days you left the comment to
keep the streak going and it's not just
giving you the information in that video
but you're the kind of person that
follows through and if you start with
that video you're much more likely to
the next thing and the next thing and
the next thing and so create a daily
routine to support you and set you up
for success and make the first thing
super easy to do so that you're going to
follow through and keep the next one
going and the next one going from the
Mexican joint number three is your
environment matters more than you think
there's a reason why people say you are
the result of the five people closest to
you in your life your environment really
really really matters and most people
have big goals of what you want to
accomplish but they don't have the
current environment around them that
help support them achieving that big
goal and so look at your friends look at
the people who you hang out with look at
the the magazine's you're reading and
the videos you're watching do they
consistently help you become that person
that you want to become or your friends
pushing you and dieting and motivating
you and supporting you or they telling
you you can't do that you're never going
to make it you're not going to have
success who do you think you are to go
up and do that big scary thing and so
your environment matters because if
you're hanging around these people who
are just putting you down then what are
you going to do you're going to have
moments of boldness
and you're going to shrink back down if
you want to be here but your
environments keeping you here and so
whether it's joining the meetup group or
watching YouTube videos or looking at
your physical environment what's on the
walls what's on the background of your
phone and your computer you want to be
around the things that make you come
alive and force you this thing's big and
bold consistently it's why I helped
create this YouTube channel wasn't just
for you guys it's for me because I want
to be around successful people doing big
bold scary things so that I don't wake
up and just be comfortable every day so
I'm still pushing myself to get up and
do bigger and bolder things every single
day
[Music]
the fourth truth is you don't need
anyone's permission so from my personal
experience when I have to make a variety
of career changes in my life going from
a police officer in training to going
into sales to thinking of being a
marriage counselor and all these things
I needed to make sure that I do right by
me and so when I think of the leg
decisions that I have made in my life I
think of myself and like in 40 or 50
years let's say I'm lying on my deathbed
what kind of regrets do I not want to
have I read an interesting blog post by
an Australian nurse who takes care of
dying people
she mentioned five things that were in
common with a huge number of people and
what they worried about what kind of
fears they had to kind of think they
said interesting enough three that
really stood out for me one a lot of
them said I wish I let myself be happier
second point is I wish I had the courage
to express my true feelings and the
third one was I wish I had the courage
to live life to my true self and not
live to someone else's expectations so
when you think of your life right now
and if you imagine in 40 years maybe you
want to try a new job maybe you want to
do a dance class maybe you want to ask
someone out are you waiting for
permission and the funny thing is
sometimes it's not from other people
sometimes it's just from yourself
sometimes you're getting in your own way
because of fear of failure because of
fear of rejection a variety things I'm
going to tell you right now it is an
incredible
stealing when you let that go and you
feel that you deserve all the happiness
that's out there waiting for you just
make sure you consider it next time you
get excited about something next time
you feel passionate about something next
time you feel a little bit scared but
you want to try something just do it
don't get in your way don't let others
get in the way you don't need other
people's permission at the end of the
day 30 40 years from now I want you to
make sure that you're not living with
regrets so be free and be happy tooth
number five is modeling successful
shortcut your path whatever you're
trying to figure it out whatever goal
you have whatever ambition that you want
to go and create somebody has already
done it if they haven't done it exactly
they've done it pretty closely and so
the more that you can look to their
story of how they went from start up to
hitting that first big objective you can
learn from that story and apply it to
yourself if you look at Starbucks as an
example Howard Schultz the founder went
to Italy and he was on vacation with his
family and he saw how the coffee shop
was the center of life for Italians it
was their third home it has home it had
work and then they had the coffee shop
and the cafe was a secret place that
people like to hang out and belong to he
looked at the North American market and
he saw the Dunkin Donuts of the world
where it was just faster you go in you
come out you know you just get your
coffee you get your caffeine and you
leave but it wasn't seen as that third
home and so I thought why don't I just
bring this concept to North America this
concept that had worked for decades for
Italian I just bring it to North America
and that's how Starbucks was eventually
born and you can think of it as that's a
meeting place for people so people like
to spend their time between home and
work and so that model really worked for
him whatever goal you have somebody has
already figured it out and by watching
videos or by reading their stores or
listening interviews you can dissect it
and apply their rules to help you
accomplish the same goal
[Music]
juice number six is your profits will
come from your passion if you look at
anybody said success at any fields
because they had massive love for what
they're doing you have to enjoy the work
jerry Steinfeld calls it the torture
that you can endure the things that you
do that you could do day in and day out
that you love so much to other people
would look at your schedule and say that
is torture
that is crazy i can't believe how much
time you spend on it people would look
at me filming sixty videos today and say
that's nuts how do you do that all in
one day it's crazy i can barely get one
video up per week it's torture to them
but to me I love it I breathe it help
your entrepreneurs I can stay up all day
and not go to the bathroom and not eat
and forget to sleep it's because I love
helping entrepreneurs they get so
focused in that zone where the people
would look at that and say it's torture
that's when you need to find when you
find that thing that you love doing so
much and find a way to be able to apply
it to help other people that's when we
start making money your money your
profits will come by pursuing your
passion truth number seven is you can do
what you believe believe is a big thing
for me it's my one word super important
right I find it so fascinating to see
people holding themselves back not
accomplishing the thing that's that I
feel that they can built that they can
do that other people think they can do
but teachers don't have the sub
confidence in themselves there's an
expression by Henry Ford the same
whether you believe that you can or you
can't you're right if you think that
being 65 is too old to start a company
you're right
but Colonel Sanders did it and had tons
of success if you believe that being 19
is too young to start a company you're
right but lots of people have come
before you and done it there are people
who have waste fewer resources than what
you currently have right now whatever
reason you're giving yourself right now
for not being a success whether you're
blaming your government or your country
or your gender or your size or your age
or your education or your family
whatever it is that you're blaming
whatever the reason is that you think
you can't be successful there are
already people who look exactly like you
who come from worse backgrounds had less
resources and you currently have
right now and they've gone off and
achieved much bigger things than you
have if they can do it you can too you
just have to believe so that's my take
on the seven fundamental truths that
will change your life I'd love to know
what did you guys think which one was
your favorite and why what are you going
to immediately apply somehow to your
life or your business leave it down in
the comments below I'm super curious to
find out also did I miss an eight nine
ten that you want to add to the list let
me know by leaving a comment I also want
to give a quick chatter - Anthony Avena
Anthony thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word and
doing that review on your blog I really
really appreciate it man
and I'm glad you enjoyed the book so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon